okay today I'm going to talk to you
about hydrocarbons we're gonna have a
look at what hydrocarbons are and how
chain length affects their properties so
first of all we're going to have a look
at the definition of a hydrocarbon which
is this a hydrocarbon is a compound
containing hydrogen and carbon only so
this is why they're called hydrocarbons
because they attain hydrogen and carbon
the really important word to make sure
you include the definition is only there
are no other elements included in a
hydrocarbon only hydrogen and carbon so
we need to learn a little bit more about
these now so we're gonna have a look at
examples here's a hydrocarbon with two
hydrocarbons that are kind of shorter in
length and here's two that are slightly
longer in length so to understand the
properties of hydrocarbons we need to
understand a little bit more about the
bonds within them because there's two
different types of bond going on that we
need to be aware of now within a
hydrocarbon itself we have forces called
intra molecular forces these are strong
covalent bonds within the molecule
itself so it means within the molecule
the other type of force we need to know
are in turr molecular forces now
intermolecular forces means between
different hydrocarbons so if I was to
just draw them on just here it shows
attractions that are between two
different molecules now the way that I
remember this is by thinking about
intranet and Internet if you have an
intranet for example in a school it
connects all the computers within the
school itself the internet obviously
connects us with loads of other places
as well so that's the way I personally
remember even see intra and
intermolecular forces so I'm just going
to draw the intermolecular forces or
just a diagram
to show these intermolecular forces
acting on the longer chain one because
that will help us understand a few
things because what we need to do is we
need to understand how chain lengths
affect different properties to begin
with boiling point so when we boil at
one of these hydrocarbons with obviously
changing state from a liquid to a gas in
order to do that we need to break these
intermolecular forces the forces holding
the different molecules together we are
not breaking these strong intramolecular
forces
so as this evaporates we still have this
three chain hydrocarbon here which is
actually propane but we have broken
these intermolecular forces so they are
no longer being held together or
attracted towards each other using these
intermolecular forces as a result the
short of the chain the lower the boiling
point now this is because less force is
required to break these intermolecular
forces compared to if we have a longer
chain we could have attraction all the
way along the chain length so more
energy would be required in order to to
boil the longer chain ones so that's how
chain length effects boiling points next
up we need to know about this thing
called viscosity what viscosity means is
how runny or how thick a substance is so
the short of the chain length the lower
the viscosity ie it will be much runny
ER now the reason for that is
essentially if you have a if you have
longer hydrocarbons there's basically
more forces holding it together so it
will be more viscous it will be more
thick so this these kind of thick
consistency is described as having a
high viscosity so thick
a little bit like like treacle or syrup
so much thicker the final thing we need
to know about is about how easier is to
ignite the short of the chain the easier
it is to ignite now the reason that this
is shorter hydrocarbons tend to be gases
at room temperature so these gases can
mix with mix with oxygen in the air
which burst into flames nice and easy
the longer the chain the higher the
boiling point so it's less likely to be
gaseous it's more likely to be a liquid
meaning it's less easy to ignite so the
longer the chain the more difficult it
is to ignite ignite just means to set it
on fire for it to catch fire so this is
basically the features of hydrocarbons
and how chain length effects these
different properties thank you